hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers of
sand ax who wrote in about asking about
getting funding for a Youth Center so
the question was thank you every for the
past few months have been thinking of
opening a new center in our area I plan
to speak where the word counselor I
don't have any finances right now we're
thinking of asking for sponsorships and
donations what are the things that
should be aware before I take any
further steps so thank you for the
question great noble vision that you
have here to create this Youth Center a
couple of ideas for you the first thing
I would do is have a big vision let's
start small so instead of going after a
youth center which might be really
timely you know costly you know a whole
set of problems that you'll come into
trying to create this youth center and
it may frustrate you the point of
wanting to quit start with something
smaller start with a few simple events
community events that target youth and
you know build up some momentum from
those events and so you know it's easy
to show that what you're doing works
there's a reason behind it you have an
impact and then when you go to you know
build your the community center you have
some momentum behind you so that'd be my
first step is try to start on a small
scale have that big vision but start
small and start with something that's
low cost easy to set up and you can
start making an impact in the community
right away it also be rewarding for you
that you can see hey you're actually
making a difference and it doesn't
necessarily need to have a huge
community center you can do things on a
really small scale and still impact
people's lives and that will give you
the juice and the momentum and the
encouragement to want to go out and do
it more and more and more and more and
more you know when I started helping
entrepreneurs I did it just ad hoc small
scale helping individual entrepreneurs
and I've had a couple of events and it
got me hooked and I've got to do more of
this I love it gonna really expand it
and give me the fuel to want to keep
going so if you start small do a couple
things small events you can see is
having an impact it'll give you the
motivation to to want to keep going and
doing it more
the next thing if you're trying to
target sponsorship I would definitely
have a laser targeted focus so what is
it that you are trying to do or try to
get kids off the street are you trying
to encourage them to learn a certain
skill set what is the goal or the vision
of your enterprise so that would really
help a lot of people have you know mixed
bag of goals and vision that's hard to
communicate the harder it is to explain
what it is that you do and the benefits
you're going to be able to provide the
harder it is for somebody to jump on
board and want to sponsor you and or be
a customer be a partner right so you
have to really have a clear message and
the laser targeted focus on what it is
that you're doing and the reason for
your existence so you may already know
that you didn't explain it you know in
the email you sent but in all your
communications now you also want to say
here's why I'm doing this and here's
what we're gonna do to make it really
clear and then it helps you know anybody
who you're talking to you think about
ways to potentially help you so if you
just say I'm open in a Youth Center you
know there's a lot of different ways to
potentially help but if you had a
specific focus then it's gonna be easier
for people to jump on board and you may
not know that yet that's fine but before
you go start talking to companies I
definitely have that laser focus and in
the last thing I touched on that already
but it's build momentum so as much as
you can you want to show that you're not
just starting up it's really hard for
companies and for anybody really to want
to back somebody who's just getting
started
because there's so many people who start
up who aren't really serious who don't
commit to it and their enterprise falls
apart and so you need to show that
you're the one who's actually going to
succeed and you're really committed to
this and you're really going to make
sure that it happens so you can start as
I said small with the events you know
show that it's working help people out
you know sure that you can have a
meaningful impact but it'll expand on
that and try to get you know some
activity going on Facebook and YouTube
and build up a newsletter list as much
as you can to build momentum and show
that people are behind this try to get
some advisors who are maybe a little
well known in your community who can
lend their name to the project as well
so that way when you go to your sponsors
potential customers here you're able to
show them hey let me put on a couple of
bands we've had a great impact we're
building up a following on Facebook and
YouTube we have our new
we've got these local people who are
advisors to the business to the the
corporation that's something that then
somebody can look at a business can look
and say hey we want to get behind we
should be involved in this or if you
just go with an idea with zero track
record and zero momentum you're probably
gonna get a no and that just comes from
my experience in a venture capital
business you know I looked at I don't
know how many business plans too many
business plans and we rejected 99% of
them a lot of the times was because they
had zero momentum behind them just an
idea on paper is not enough to get
somebody to want to put money into your
company so you have to show them that
you've got something happening here that
they're gonna be missing out on the
opportunity and that there's this is
real you're not just the average
everyday startup who's gonna launch an
idea because they had a you know a dream
one night and then they shot it down the
next week
that's the biggest fear that people will
have but you'll just go and spend their
money and you won't be able to show them
a return so if you're already having an
impact then you're using that money to
fuel it even more and have a greater
impact so hopefully that helps if you
guys liked the video for those of you
watching I'd love it if you can give it
a thumbs up it always makes my day and
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you guys and if you have a comment
I'd love to hear from you or if you have
a question for me as well just leave it
in the comments below I'll be sure to
read and get back to you so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you